[Musique]
c'est samedi de juin cyrille melchior
président du conseil d'administration du
19 7 4 et président du département et le
colonel hervé bertoua directeur
départemental annonce dans le cadre de
la politique de développement du
volontariat de l'établissement
l'engagement de 114 sapeurs pompiers
volontaires afin de renforcer son
effectif opérationnel
c'est un geste fort aussi bien pour nous
qui les accueille au et je l'espère pour
eux qu'ils rejoignent la grande famille
des sapeurs pompiers
il faut en partie des 2500 pompiers qui
seront un jour qui feront partie à jour
10 6 et la réunion aujourd'hui nous ne
sommes pas très loin ici deux trois ans
nous serons 2500 c'est l'objectif qui
nous est assignée lors de cette
cérémonie
ils ont tous signé la charte nationale
des sapeurs pompiers volontaires et se
sont vu remettre la part et et
d'engagement et d'affectation de la main
de leur autorité de gestion ainsi qu'un
partage opérationnelle minimum afin de
pouvoir démarrer leur formation c'est la
première fois qu'en ma qualité de
président que je reçois plus de 100
jeunes sapeurs pompiers volontaires
c'est un honneur pour moi je les
recevoir parce que ils ont fait un choix
qui les honore c'est celui de ses amis à
la population
issu à taux de participer à la sécurité
de nos concitoyens
donc c'est un très beau choix je les
félicite pour leur engagement
je félicite aussi bien sur les dix
réunions les colonels l'encadrement les
personnels pour faciliter formé
accueillir ces sapeurs pompiers
volontaires et je vous le dis je le
redis le stis nous voulons d'un indice
fort organisé au service de nos
concitoyens
les sapeurs pompiers volontaires
participent activement à ce travail au
bénéfice de la sécurité des
réunionnaises et des réunionnais
[Musique]